[Music]
[Applause]
yeah fan Corrections this is a segment
where viewers try to find mistakes on
our show why do I try to do this because
we dare them to write we say yo cuz we
know how to talk to you sure imagine us
wearing hats with the brims on sideways
we're like yo yo right find a mistake
bro that's what we do anyway so far
whatever so far hundreds and hundreds of
challengers a lot of challengers not one
winner not one person has caught us
making a mistake in the years that we've
been here at TBS well tonight a fan
named cow skull I think is how it's
pronounced says he thinks he caught a
mistake he says it happened during my
interview with Big Bang Theory star
Kunal Nayyar take a look Conan I got you
right now you can't even get away from
this one you had that dude that one dude
from The Big Bang Theory on there and he
said Turtles and a half shop Teenage
Mutant Ninja Turtles Teenage Mutant
Ninja Turtles turtles and a half shell
to the power you're on it's heroes in a
half-shell
[Applause]
first of all cow skull if you're gonna
go through the trouble of sending in a
fan correction get my guest name right
okay he's not the one guy from Big Bang
Theory how would you like it if I just
called you the one guy who works
part-time at lids you wouldn't like it
[Applause]
I'm just curious to is that woman there
against her will I don't have let her go
and I think it looks almost like she was
making a fan correction and then he
horned in on that's that I don't think
so well anyway cow skull I think you got
bad news for you you are dead dead wrong
you see the lyrics to the Teenage Mutant
Ninja Turtles cartoon theme song it
actually were Turtles in a half-shell
that is until they had to change the
lyrics because a cup a controversy in
Croatia where those words meant
something very very different when the
cartoon was translated and then they had
to later on change the words are the
ones you know don't believe me check out
this 1987 archival footage footage you
can't fake from Croatia's version of mtv
okay so writing continuing across
Croatia over American cartoon teenage
turtle ninjas where everyone so many
turtles is because team song contains
very offensive language to Croatian
peoples in sony says turtles in a
half-shell
but in Croatia this is expression
meaning my balls are inside your angry
and destroying turtle ninja recording
this form of protest
that's right it was versus real fair
that's right they had to change the
lyrics because of the ruckus in Croatia
and as a special treat not you brought
it up cow skull
we found the musicians who recorded the
Teenage Mutant Ninja Turtles theme
they're here tonight to perform the song
with its original lyrics yes pre Croatia
controversy for the first time in almost
30 years this is exciting great to be
here it's great to be anywhere really
it really is business has been slow not
kidding all right here we go
[Music]
[Applause]
he's a vegetable
hey thanks for watching be sure to click
subscribe to see even more great Conan
clips you may now return to your pirated
movies and creepy Japanese pornography